[Music]
that complicated interracial against who
played Natasha as a fully realized woman
[Applause]
we're continuing the legacy of the MCU
and we're going to do that in new ways
unexpected ways and really build on the
legacy of what's come before
with this and giving us the other side
of twin barn that you haven't seen
importance
and what if we're going to explore
corners of the universe that might be
untouched which is really exciting I am
burdened with glorious service one of
the biggest questions that audiences had
coming out of a game is where did Loki
go this series will answer that
great thing about one division is that
we get to see what an ideal life for one
that vision actually looks like
[Music]
we're gonna make the first scary MCU
bill
the 10 ranks has been in the MCU since
the very beginning
turtles are the really special group of
people that will feel different than
anything we've done before
this show is gonna be about two
characters that have to come simply
stand favorites
[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Marvel phase 4 trailer breakdown
we have black widow footage to break
down we have a bunch of eternal stuff we
finally found out who Kit Harington is
going to be playing in the MCU Tom
Hollands spider-man was even on stage at
d23 after the Marvel movies panel how
awkward is that I guarantee you they're
not gonna let him do interviews this
weekend this video will be about mostly
the movie stuff that they reveal there
was a bunch of TV stuff and previews
that they released this weekend too like
during that trailer you see a bunch of
footage from the other TV series during
Marvel pays for this is a new round of
the Avengers endgame and spider-man far
from home blu-ray giveaways all you have
to do to enter those would be a
subscriber and leave your best Marvel
phase 4 theory on the video starting
with number 5 the Black Widow trailer
footage so you see her in yellow and
Belova just going at it so a little bit
of that clip is from the comic-con
trailer that they showed off a couple
weeks ago there was also some separate
footage that they screened that they
didn't allow anyone to record with a
Natasha black widow in a full white suit
that we've never seen her in before
fighting yelling at biloba so there's a
lot of one-upsmanship that goes on
between them that also harkens back to
their comic book back story where Jelena
Bulova for a brief time was trying to
take the mantle of Black Widow from her
or the lead Black Widow because
technically they're all called black
widows you think of them as like sisters
that are fighting with each other one
thinking they're better than the other
Jelena Bulova trying to show up the
Natasha Black Widow during their fight
yelling a biloba starts mocking Natasha
black widows pose calling her a poser
look your pose is terrible you're a
total poser the other footage they
showed off actually does show her having
a really badass Throwdown fight with
taskmaster and it kind of explains his
abilities to his ability to instantly
learn other people's moves and copy them
and make them better he chases her down
causes her to crash then they get into a
knock-down drag-out fight her moves are
actually pretty badass during the movie
very John wick fighting style I actually
do think that they got the fight
choreographer from John wick which makes
me way more excited about what's going
on with the action scenes you've seen a
little bit of black widows fighting
style in all the movies she's been in so
she starts to one-up him a little bit
but then slowly you start to see him
counter her move
within a couple moments he's copying her
move to move in they're fighting each
other to a standstill then he brings his
shield out
sheriff hopper from stranger things is
playing Alexi szostak off the red
guardian I've already talked a lot about
his character in the last big black
widow trailer video that I did so I'll
link that at the end of this I included
a clip in that where he talks a little
bit about how his character is fun very
different relationship with Natasha
black widow in the past then he doesn't
present day because remember she used to
be full-on team member of the Red Room
before Hawkeye found her in Budapest and
brought her into the Avengers and taught
her sort of a better way of life like
you can get you get some of this read
off of your ledger that's the idea the
Black Widow movie is explaining a lot of
those comments that she makes and the
Budapest jokes that they tell each other
in all the Avengers films early theory
about the end of that movie Hawkeye
shows up in a cameo and that offers to
bring her into shield for Nick Fury
because Nick Fury is actually the one
that sent Hawkeye to check out Black
Widow way way back before she became a
member of the team number four there was
a whole bunch of other clips during that
obviously some of that's from the TV
shows some of this from the movies so
you have the Hawkeye series clip there's
a what-if clip with a brief explainer of
the series a Loki series clip some
footage from the wan division show a
clip from Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness a clip from
Schanke in the legend of the ten rings
in Eternals clip I'll talk about the
Eternals panel in a second too at d23
because they bought everybody out on
stage with some concept art of what
their characters actually look like in a
lot of the Kit Harington news is part of
that Eternals news and then obviously
showing off a clip from Falcon and
Winter Soldier that's actually gonna be
the very first Disney Plus series to
premiere remember Baron Zemo is gonna be
the main villain of that I will do like
a separate really big video for all the
Marvel phase 4 TV series because they
announce Moon Knight she-hulk Kamala
Khan Miss Marvel there's a whole bunch
of other stuff that they dropped this
weekend three breaking down the big
eternals preview that they just had a
couple hours ago as of me posting this
video so kid Harrington from Game of
Thrones confirmed to be joining the
Eternals as Dayne Whitman aka the Black
Knight everybody wondering if the Black
Knight was gonna join the MCU there were
rumors about him during spider-man far
from home and during Avengers endgame
now it's finally confirmed he's going to
be joining the Eternals movie I'll
explain what his
connection to those characters are
because if you're a super huge comic
book fan you will remember that he is
one of the earliest newer team members
from the classic Avengers comics like
way back Avengers I think it was 47 when
he debuted back in the 60s
so he goes way way back with the
Avengers remember the Eternals movie
takes place in the distant past of the
MCU but also takes place in present day
because their quote-unquote eternal they
reincarnate so that's how you sort of
bridged the timeline of the MCU going
back to the dawn of the universe the
Celestials then the dawn of mankind on
earth in now what's happening in present
day post Avengers endgame they also can
burn the Jemma Chan from the Captain
Marvel movie who played a Creed during
that is going to be playing a different
character on the Eternals she will be a
Cersei for a long time when they
announced Angelina Jolie people thought
that she would be playing Cersei but
she's actually playing thena Jemma Chan
will be Cersei I'm probably gonna
mispronounce his name but Barry Kyojin
is playing drew aghh he's initially kind
of the main villain he's a deviant but
he's on stage with them here in this
roster so it seems like they're implying
that he's going to be one of the more
dysfunctional members of their family
they'll be a couple changes to the comic
book but I did a big Eternals preview
video yesterday explaining the comic
book story that they're basing the movie
on and it's mostly Neil Gaiman 'he's
Eternals and drew league technically
isn't the main villain at the beginning
of that story just looking at this
preview of all their characters here
going left to right so on the Left
Richard Madden is playing the lead he's
Icarus Kumail Nanjiani is king go Lauren
read law from The Walking Dead is Macari
Bryan Tyree Henry who you'll recognize
from spider-man into the spider versus
fastest he played Miles Morales his
father during spider-verse she only
heard his voice but I believe he was
also in a couple other Marvel films as
minor characters Salma Hayek is playing
Ajax she's sort of the administrator of
the group within the movie even though
technically they're all God level power
and worshiped by the people of Earth as
gods
technically they do have a power
structure and there is a leader of the
group Lea McHugh is playing sprite she's
the same age as all these others but
when they became Eternals when they were
modified by the Celestials she was the
little girl so would be like a little
girl being turned into a vampire
could be thousands of years old and she
still looks like a little girl dongseok
ma is gilgamesh here Angelina Jolie is
playing thena she'll be blond in the
movie just like comic-book Athena that's
why her hair's blonde in this preview
probably mispronouncing his name again
but the person on her right berry
Keoghan
is Drew II in his comic-book uniform in
the last person who you don't really see
on stage here is Jemma Chan playing
Cersei but you see a picture of her
character the connection between kit
harington's Black Knight character in
the Eternals characters at least in the
comics going way way back to those
original Avengers crossovers is that for
a brief period the Black Knight was
romantically involved with Circe's
character she started to go mad but for
the most part he's meant to be a hero
even though technically the Black Knight
makes him sound like a villain he is a
good character he was a member of the
Avengers briefly in the classic comics
the backstory of the character though is
that he's a genetic descendant of the
original Black Knight from the King
Arthur Chronicles but he's technically
the third version of the character he's
just a modern-day descendant of the
original Black Knight and all the
concept art that you see the character
he's wielding his special sword that's
what gives him his powers it's called
the ebony blade it's been passed down
through the ages but it carries a
terrible curse anyone who wields it will
slowly go mad so the longer he uses it
the crazier and crazier he gets it'll be
interesting to see how they incorporate
that into the movie but he's mostly a
normal person he only has special powers
when he's wielding the ebony blade -
they confirm that Black Panther - is
dropping may 6 2015 1 coming back they
do have a brand new main villain the
reason why they probably didn't reveal
who that was they wouldn't say who the
new villain is because wait for it it's
probably going to be a mutant character
aka Namor or one of the other big ones
from the Fox Marvel group the reason why
people think that Black Panther 2 is
going to be the first big Marvel MCU
movie that incorporates Fox Marvel
characters or mutant characters is
because it's not happening until 2022 so
you already have most of Marvel phase
forward to sort of spin out the logic of
how mutants can exist in the MCU in
number one major awkward moment Tom
Hollands spider-man
was onstage at d23 he has another Pixar
movie that's coming out they were doing
a presentation for Chris Pratt is also
on that movie so both of them were on
stage together presenting right after
the big Marvel panel it was the most
awkward thing ever there were people in
the crowd screaming spider-man at him
during the panel
he said something briefly they did not
let him do interviews as you would
expect because all this craziness with
Marvel and Sony there's no way that's
gonna let Tom Holland do any interviews
this weekend I'm kind of waiting for
some more updates and developments on
the situation between Marvel and Sony
before doing another spider-man video
because it is changing day to day but
things are relatively hopeful so it's
not completely over at this point
between the two I know you guys are all
going crazy about all the new stuff they
announced it's a Marvel phase four TV
panel for Disney plus yesterday I will
do a video for that next that should
post on Sunday post all your reactions
in the comments everybody go crazy it's
gonna be awesome
congratulations thrash maniac 99 you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details yes the Eternals will also
be very important for explaining how
mutants exist in the MCU and we just
haven't seen them till now so everybody
click here for my big Marvel phase four
Eternals preview video that I just
posted and click here to rewatch the
Star Wars Mandalorian trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you